a rare Israeli air strike in the
occupied West Bank the Target Two
Palestinians in a mosque in the J
refugee
camp I was under this window and heard a
loud explosion just after 2 a.m. there's
no place for us to go so we stayed
home Israeli troops usually Waid the
camp in the north of the West Bank of an
exchanging fire with Palestinian
Fighters This Time Israeli s solders
were nowhere to be found a dangerous
escalation Palestinians
say the Israeli Army says the two people
targeted were responsible for previous
attacks and were planning new
ones following the strike some families
say Israeli forces called them
threatening to kill other wanted
[Music]
Palestinians with these assassinations
it's clear that the the Israeli forces
are starting to copy what they're doing
in the besieged Gaza Strip in the
occupied West Bank
too this is our fear that these
assassinations will come from the air
this is a big problem because when you
hit an area you damage the
surroundings Israeli forces have been
ramping up their raids and increasing
their use of aerial attacks in the West
Bank particularly in areas where armed
groups are active on Thursday a drone
strike killed at least five Palestinians
in the N refugee camp near tarim with
more than a dozen Israeli raids on
average per day and a growing number of
casualties many here fear that the
Flames of Israel's war on Gaza are
catching up in the West Bank nid ibraim
Al jaaz R let's go live to sah in rala
in the occupied West Bank let's start
with that raid we were talking about
about the the two Palestinians who were
killed doing that raid in the town of of
nablo what more do we know about
that Rob well um we know that two people
were killed including a teenager and
this is uh one of the latest raids that
had happened um in 24 hours where
multiple raids were carried out across
occupied West Bank and since that one in
nais there have been plenty more in uh
the usual areas that you see such as tul
Karam uh just outside of rala over over
here and also um the latest uh there's
been a few arrests including in jalon
refugee camp it's one of the uh bigger
refugee camps here in occupied West Bank
for uh Palestinians that originally had
turned up there in 1948 when they were
kicked out of their homes now um
interestingly what seems to be to have
taken a really Sinister uh turn is that
it seems and that's what we're hearing
it's not confirmed though and from
Palestinians that are talking about this
is that one of the people that was
arrested um he then had a social media
post put up on his uh Facebook page soon
after that arrest with the Israeli flag
and written in text was that don't mess
around with the Israeli Army it seems to
become it it seems to become a lot more
personal at the moment also in that
refugee camp um during that raid it
seems that posters have also been put up
um warning uh people to not show
solidarity um with those that are in
Gaza but it's also saying don't let this
be another Gaza and it warned that they
would revoke uh work permits if they
were seen to be supporting Hamas or of
course any of the Armed groups in the
West Bank so it's really taking and
escalating into another level that's
been not been seen certainly not
recently in occupied West Bank these are
just not the usual raids the daily raids
that we do see here that happen all the
time but now it's becoming a lot more
personal yeah I understand that there
have been some more protests in the
occupied West Bank in the last few hours
what's been happening
there um yeah there were a few sporadic
uh uh protests that happened in several
parts of occupied West Bank including
just um to the square here on my right
um and the same at the same time we were
also seeing that in the Le capital
bayout and a couple more other places in
uh Lebanon all happening at the same
time they weren't that big it started
around 3 a.m. so most people most
Palestinians certainly would have been
asleep but it's off the back of every
time um there's huge uh a huge number of
air strikes which is exactly what we
have seen and some of the most ferocious
bombardment right now uh from Israel
onto Gaza that's when um um youth get
together and they rally each other up
and they head to the street it didn't
last for long but again it's just
showing you that all of those that are
in occupied territories all the
Palestinians um are very much concerned
uh to the situation in Gaza and they are
also feeling those repercussions uh of
Israel it seems in their words saying
that it's taking Revenge uh uh not just
against Hamas but it seems Collective
punishment against Palestinian people
Sarah Kat in the occupied West Bank
Sarah thank you